We said earlier that the square root of the number n is just a number that when
multiplied by itself, gives us n. Let's pick a real number to make this more
concrete for ourselves, though. Right now, I am feeling 3. 3 is the number that
I want to use right now. But what number times itself gives us 3? Well, we just
said that was the whole point of square roots. So clearly, the square root of 3
times the square root of 3 equals 3. But this is interesting. The square root of
3 times the square root of 3 is just the square root of 3 squared. So, what does
this mean for square roots in terms of exponents? What if I wanted to rewrite
this as 3 to some power, all of that squared, equals 3. What number belongs in
this box?